ils ont moins de 35 ans représentent
plus de 60% de la population et avec
leur look branché
beaucoup d'entre eux défi l'image que
l'on se fait d'une république islamique
soumise aux diktats des ayatollahs c'est
en grande partie cette jeunesse qui a
servi une défaite sévère aux
fondamentalistes ultraconservateur lors
des élections tenues vendredi dernier
pour le parlement et l'assemblée des
experts environ certains sont juste
assez âgé pour avoir vu leur vie entière
basculé avec l'imposition des sanctions
économiques contre leur pays
il y a près de dix ans c'est le cas de
babak la compagne italienne qui
l'employait à plier bagage en moins de
24 heures
quand on leur offre mon agent a
graduellement le taux de chômage
l'inflation et la pauvreté ont grimpé en
iran mais depuis l'accord sur le
nucléaire avec les grandes puissances et
la levée partielle des sanctions babac
retrouvent espoir à emilie date jean
even if ever a space ark close your eyes
band while some people want some people
who believe et alès note
michael fuchs de sochaux freedom cazals
elle croît moins au changement la jeune
femme de 22 ans à l'optimisme beaucoup
plus prudent moreau a sans droit ni un
conservateur modéré s'est fait élire à
la présidence en 2013 en promettant des
changements économiques bien sûr en
renouant avec le monde extérieur mais
aussi plus de liberté pour les iraniens
mais dans une société où le guide
suprême l'ayatollah ali khameini figure
religieuse autocratique est l'ultime
responsable de tout les discussions sur
les changements sociaux et culturels qui
sont chers à classe moyenne éduquée
demeure quasi tabou les changements de
base on ne peut pas attendre en iran
c'est à dire c'était une révolution en
iran ce révolution c'est le peuple qui a
fait le choix de la république islamique
alors que le peuple est favorable à la
république islamique se dire où il faut
pas attendre de changement comment dire
sociaux qu'une minorité
les attentes mots le professeur de
relations internationales crois que le
président hu a ni son entourage pourrait
bien avoir trop promis et risque d'en
payer le prix
leurs informateurs ils ont fait penser
aux gens qu'il y aura beaucoup de
changements
ça c'est un risque attendu ce que nous
voyons en or il ya une partie des
embargos qui sont mauvais et il ya eu de
nouvel embargo après à près de cinq ans
c'est une scène de plus en plus
fréquentes en iran depuis la levée
partielle des sanctions économiques
d'affaires diplomates et politiciens
sud-coréen cela se bouscule pour
explorer possibilités d'investissement
dans un marché qui leur étaient jusque
là inaccessibles cet ancien représentant
de la poudrière shell en iran avant
l'embargo se range du côté des
optimistes
il ne manque plus de travail depuis
qu'il agit à titre de consultant pour
les compagnies étrangères tenté par
l'aventuré iranienne parmi elles une
chaîne canadienne de peur de gaulle
ils ont ainsi dit lundi sur europe 1
tout ou presque est à refaire en iran
mais le gouvernement manque de capitaux
nécessaires pour se lancer dans une
refonte complète de son économie
une statine possibilité d'un échange
l'iran et son peuple ont beaucoup à
offrir aux consultants durablement ce
chiot de l'énergie cre
il y aura pipeau les saucisses des
années j'ai répondu oui comme si nous y
atteler iseli conseil régional 10 heures
une bonne partie de la jeunesse
iranienne dont pas maqué cazals crois
que le moment est aussi venu pour leur
pays d'être perçue autrement des
messages sms via the world we can't even
if en deux coloris
quand il entre les fondamentalistes et
les conservateurs ont perdu une manche
aux dernières élections les il reste une
force politique incontournable et les
jeunes majoritaire qui ont fait entendre
leur voix espère seulement que leur
génération aura plus d espace pour
définir l'iran pour qu'ils aspirent